We're asked, what's the
first wrong statement
in the proof below that
triangle BCE-- so that's
this middle triangle
right over here--
is congruent to triangle BCA?
That's this top triangle
right over there.
And they tell us that
BC is parallel to DF
and that the diagram
is not drawn to scale.
Fair enough.
So we're essentially
going to check their proof
to see if it's either
correct or if there's
a wrong statement in it.
So let's look at the givens.
They tell us that angle BAC
is congruent to angle BED.
AC is congruent to DE.
ACB congruent to BDE.
So this is BDE.
This is ACB.
BC is congruent to CF.
Just double-click there
to get the two slashes.
Angle ABC is congruent
to angle CFE.
So that's this one.
Triple-click there
to get three of those
to show that that's not
necessarily congruent,
or we don't know whether
they're congruent
to these other angles.
So that's those two.
And then angle BAC, which
we've already marked,
is congruent to CEF.
So this angle is
congruent to this one.
So this one will
be just one slash.
So now let's go
through their proof
and see if it
makes actual sense.
So this first
statement they make
is, BDE is congruent to BCA
because of angle side angle.
Let's see.
It looks like that's
right because you
have your double arc angle,
then your single side, and then
your single arc angle.
So you have angle, side, angle.
It is legitimate.
This is a legitimate
statement here.
So I'm cool with that.
That's not going
to be incorrect.
Then they say angle
ACB is congruent to DBE
because vertical
angles are equal.
Well, this makes
absolutely no sense.
Those aren't vertical angles.
Those just aren't
vertical angles.
Actually, the way that
this is drawn here,
there aren't any
vertical angles.
But ACB and DBE are definitely
not vertical angles.
So we're actually done.
We have found the
incorrect statement.
This is not true.
ACB is not congruent to DBE
because of vertical angles.
So the wrong statement
in this proof
was the statement
that tries to do
that because of vertical angles.
So let's check our answer.
And it is correct.